(fast classical organ music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is
Professor Harold Hongju Koh,
who is the Gerard C. and
Bernice Latrobe Smith
Professor of International Law at Yale.
He has served as assistant secretary
for Democracy Human Rights and Labor
in the United States Department of State
from 1998 to 2001.
His publications include
Deliberative Democracy
with Robert C. Sly and the
National Security Constitution.
Professor Koh, welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you for having me.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in Boston.
My parents both came as
students from South Korea.
My father was the first Korean, I think,
to study law in America.
And my mother is a sociologist.
- Uh-huh, and looking back,
how did your parents shape
your thinking about the world?
- Totally, my father came at the time
when Korea was controlled by
the Syngman Rhee democracy, dictatorship
and when it was overthrown,
he went back to campaign
for the first democratic
government of Korea.
And when that government was elected,
he was appointed ambassador
to the United Nations
and then minister to the United States.
And then his government, the
new democratic government,
was overthrown by military coup
and my father refused to
serve the dictatorship
and spent the rest of his life in America.
And that's how I grew up here.
So, when I became an
Assistant Secretary of State
for a democracy for the United States,
I went back to Korea,
it was an important way
of bringing my whole
family's life full circle.
- And what about the
influence of your mother?
- Well, my mother's a sociologist
and she's an expert on
comparative cultures.
She's one of the leaders
of the women's rights movement in Korea.
And I think she is the
person who most influenced me
on how to understand human relations
and you know, that's become
a critical part of what I do,
both as a lawyer and as a diplomat.
- So, was there a lot
of talk about politics
around the dinner table
as you were growing up?
- Yeah, I have five
siblings, my older brother
was a Commissioner of Public
Health of Massachusetts.
- Oh, I see!
- He just recently became a professor
at Harvard Public Health School.
I have a number of siblings for academics.
One of my sisters, Jean Koh Peters,
is my colleague at Yale Law School.
- So, it's fair to say
that your whole upbringing
was a transnational process
in itself, actually.
- Well, I think what I
was told quite early was,
if you're going to be
between two cultures,
why don't you use your bi-cultural
background as an asset?
And that then immediately
meant I should be
a diplomat or a lawyer or an academic.
- And so, but the final
choice was law, why is that?
Just because of the the
influence of your father,
or the example he set?
- Well, I started out as a physics major
and my disadvantage was that
I wasn't that good in physics.
(laughing)
I quite literally one day
was going to a physics lab
and somebody else was going to
a US and East Asia course
and I turned around
and went to that course
and I haven't looked back.
- And did you have any mentors
in law school or even as an undergraduate?
You went to Harvard, I
think, in both cases,
who really made an impression on you
and further defined the direction
that your life was gonna take.
- Yeah, in college, two
mentors, I had Paul Freund
who was a professor Harvard Law School
and Edwin Reischauer who is
a US Ambassador to Japan.
In law school,
Arthur Miller, who was a
professor of Civil Procedure
and Abram Chayes,
who wrote about
international legal process
and it's really his ideas of
that I've tried to develop in
transnational legal process.
Interestingly, two people
who I didn't study
with, Steiner and Vagts,
are now people with whom
I co-authored a book
on transnational legal problems
and transnational business problems,
which are also part of
my whole approach now.
- Let's start talking about
your service in the government,
because you actually started early
as a law clerk to a Supreme
Court Justice, right?
And that is this junket from the campus
to the halls of power,
I shouldn't say junket,
I mean journey, let's say journey.
- My first year I clerked
for Malcolm Wilkie
who is a Judge of the US Court of Appeals.
So, the DC Circuit.
He went on to be ambassador to Uruguay
and very internationalist,
he was one of the advisors
of the Restatement of
Foreign Relations Law.
I then clerked for Harry
Blackmun, who among other things
I think was the most internationalist
Supreme Court Justice
we've had in some time.
Then I worked for a big law
firm Covington & Burling,
which was Dean Acheson's firm,
and then for the Justice Department
in the Reagan administration,
and there I worked on
the suit by Nicaragua
against the United
States at the World Court
and the ratification of
the Genocide Convention.
And then I came to Yale and
I taught international trade
and international business transactions.
Then after 1990,
I decided to do more in
the human rights area
and I started with
another colleague a clinic
that would litigate Human Rights cases
and that clinic started
out doing alien tort cases
and then we ended up
representing Haitian refugees
and soon I was representing
Haitian refugees on Guantanamo and
argue that case at the Supreme Court,
and then we ended up litigating
against the Clinton administration.
And so, it was with a big
surprise that in 1998,
I get a call from my former student
who is Madeleine Albright's
advisor and he said,
how would you like to be
Madeleine Albright's Human Rights adviser?
And I said, you know,
I spent most of my time
suing the Clinton administration.
- I see.
- And he said, that's why we want you.
You know, you're nobody's yes-man
and everybody knows where you stand
and it will give us
credibility to have you.
So, I went in
and that was during the period of Kosovo,
East Timor, Sierra Leone.
It was the last years of
the Clinton administration.
And I actually think
that was a very good time
for Human Rights, particularly
looking back on it
from a post-9/11 perspective.
- We'll talk about that in a minute,
but let me go back a minute, so, what is,
what you've just described
is, it must have given you
amazing insight into the differences
being in the ivory tower
and then being in the halls
of power and seeing this
very important distinction
between theory and practice.
Looking back, what are your observations
that you want to share with us about
the differences between these two worlds?
- Well, my father I said
was my greatest teacher.
In 1974, I was in Korea
doing some research for
my undergraduate thesis
and there's an attempt on
the life of the President,
and that was the same, and
they imposed martial law.
And that same summer, Nixon resigned.
Gerald Ford became president.
And I called my father and
I said, isn't it amazing
that the largest country in the world
is changing power without
any guns or anything,
guns in the street or
any shots being fired
and Korea has never had
a peaceful transition of government?
And he said, that's the difference
between dictatorship and democracy.
He said, in a democracy,
when you're president,
the troops obey you.
He said, in a dictatorship,
when the troops obey you,
then you're president.
And that to me was the first
time I really had a sense
of the importance of
understanding of the world,
how the world worked,
another thing he said was,
theory without practice is as
lifeless as practice without
theory is thoughtless.
And so, I think partly because of that
I became convinced that I had to somehow
make my academic work relevant
to what was happening in the real world.
And when I got to the State
Department, I was struck,
I've said this in a number of saying,
that people with ideas have no influence
and people with influence have no ideas.
The people are making decisions
often have no time to
consult anything academic,
but if they do,
it's not written clearly enough
for them to be able to apply it.
On the other hand, the people with ideas
who do have time to
think about these things
often don't present their ideas
in a way that they can be used
by those who are trying to make decisions.
So, I've tried to try to breach
that gap as much as I can.
- And you're suggesting that
the potential for synergy is very great,
but that mediation is required
between these two worlds,
is that a fair assessment
Of what you see?
- Oh, very much so.
When I was in the government,
every day matters would
arise on which I'd think,
how can I be making this decision
in such a short term focus?
Somebody must have written about this,
somebody must have put this into a pattern
and I'd like to know what that pattern is.
And I would send my staff out
to look for these articles and books,
but very often what they
came with, back with,
was so tangential
and so abstract that I couldn't
use it, it didn't help me.
And I think when I went
back into academia in 2001,
part of my thought was,
I need to figure out a
way to bridge this divide.
- And what is the key to doing that?
I mean, having been in both places
and know what the,
the common link might be?
- Yeah well, for me as a lawyer,
one of my particular focal points is on
how law influences
political decision-making
and I think many political
scientists assume
that law is somehow there,
but it's not really a factor.
I think, particularly
after September 11th,
people said, you know,
what's law got to do with it?
You know, this is just about power.
Everything that we did for 50 years
creating this legal structure
is somehow thrown out the window.
I think what I've tried to
do and my work is to argue,
here's how law affects political choices.
If you do things with law
behind you, you're stronger.
If you do things in the face of law,
or in violation of law, you're weaker.
- Now, my training is in political science
and you know the old saying
in political science is,
well, can you really have a system of law?
I'm simplifying here.
If you don't have a cop on the beat
and of course in international relations,
there's no cop on the beat
except somebody with enough
power to take an action.
How do you respond to that?
Because clearly, law is more important,
international law more
important than it ever was,
but as you just suggested,
it's harder to make people see
that in the first instance.
- I guess I'd ask you this.
Do we have burglaries in Berkeley?
- Yes.
- Well, you know, the fact that the law,
domestic law is under enforced
or imperfectly enforced
doesn't mean it's not enforced.
And the core way in which
you enforced law in Berkeley,
Berkeley law is not by coercion,
but by norm internalization.
You know, people internalize
a norm against burglary.
And I would argue in the
same way internationally.
There is a system of international law.
It's imperfectly enforced,
it's under enforced,
but again, the same mechanism is at work,
norm internalization.
You know, why don't nations
attack each other all the time
and take them over?
You know, maybe it's because
they fear coercion or sanction,
but in fact, it's because of a sense
of internalized restraint.
You know, why don't people
sitting next to each other
in a restaurant in Berkeley
get up and start punching each other?
Maybe if they did,
they might get arrested for
disorderly conduct, but in fact,
it's because of a sense
of internalized restraint.
So, the element I'm trying to find is,
what is it that
internalizes this restraint?
How do you bring international law home?
And that's been the focus of my research,
particularly since I came
back from the government.
- And, and...
America before 9/11
and the current administration really had
an important
voice in making that
internalization possible
for other countries.
I mean, we had a lot of power.
We could have pushed people around,
used force and coercion, but we actually
tried to influence other nations
by setting up this
process of internalization
that you've just described.
- Well, when I came to the government,
the first conclusion I reached was that
the rule of law should be on the US side.
You know, there's a system of
law that we helped to create.
We sought it in our self-interest
and we accepted certain constraints
because we thought that in the long run,
the overall costs and benefits,
the benefits far outweighed the costs.
So, that's why we support
various systems of
international adjudication.
That's why we support the UN system.
We need these institutions,
even if they cut our own
sovereignty a little bit.
And I think that in the
post-Berlin Wall period,
there was a feeling that
this is a chance for the system
to really become effective.
And I now view this period
from 1989 to September 2001
as a period of global
optimism where people thought,
we can really use global cooperation
to solve global problems.
One of those problems is AIDS,
another is global warming,
another is international crimes,
another is terrorism.
Then 9/11 came along
and there were suddenly
two radically different
views as to how to respond.
One group said, just forget this,
throw it all out the window.
The other said, look the same
approach should still apply.
Use global cooperation
to solve global problems.
And I think the
administration that came in
took the first approach.
Let's go it alone, let's
do it unilaterally.
You know, they broke out
of the Kyoto Protocol.
They turned away from the
ICC, they attacked Iraq
with a coalition of the willing
rather than with the UN support,
and now they're surprised
when they've alienated
the people who they need to rebuild Iraq.
And I think that that's what
makes this point in time,
2003, an interesting watershed.
The question is, will the
United States continue to be
the world's primary advocate
of norm-based internationalism,
or are we gonna put forward
a sort of power-based
internationalism as our,
our prime mode of doing business.
- Before we talk about
the changes under the Bush administration,
let's go back, because
you were in a pivotal role
at a very creative time
for moving this
internationalization of norms,
that whole process further along.
Let's talk a little about that because,
you know, it's not just the
American political tradition
of dealing with these
problems that was at work,
but also the particular
leaders, academic ideas,
but also really nongovernmental
organizations and activism.
So, talk a little about that dynamic
in that very creative period
before everything hit the fan with 9/11.
- The best image that someone gave me
about being an Assistant
Secretary of State
is that you walk on to a tennis court
and someone gives you a tennis racket
and they say, the balls are
gonna start coming over the net.
And balls start coming over the net
almost faster than you can see them.
And you start trying to return them.
And then after a while,
you've returning most of them
and then they say, you say to yourself,
why not it hit them to one
place, why not have a plan?
You try to hit the ball to the left side.
And then suddenly a moment
comes where you say,
why am I not throwing the balls?
You know, why is my only approach
reactive rather than proactive?
And then you have to ask yourself,
well, what do I think are
our proactive principles?
And what I tried to do
and I think I talked
about it with Albright,
with the president was to say, you know,
there are basically four
principles we really care about.
First is telling the
truth in human rights.
Secondly, promoting
accountability for past violations
while promoting reconciliation.
Third, with regard to ongoing
abuses, present violations,
engaging violating countries
to try to get them to stop.
And with regard to the future,
preventing future abuses.
And the long-term solution
is by promoting democracy.
You know, in the end, torture, genocide.
these are not diseases, they're symptoms,
symptoms of bad government.
And so, we tried to
promote healthy government.
Now interestingly here my brother,
the Commissioner of
Public Health said to me,
I used to treat smoking patients
and then I decided if
I want to make people
not get cancer I would
encourage them not to smoke.
He said, if you promote a healthy body,
you don't have to deal with
the symptoms of disease.
And I realized in the same way,
if you promote democratic government,
you don't have to deal
with the symptoms of,
of unhealthy government.
So, those were our focal points,
truth-telling, accountability, engagement,
democracy promotion.
And you know, we had
a very exciting period
after the fall of the Berlin Wall
that was the largest expansion of freedom
in the 20th century,
the second largest came
during the time when I was in government.
Nigeria and Indonesia,
various parts of the former Soviet Union,
all switched to a democratic
form of government.
There's amazing fact, which
we uncovered, which was
that in 1971, there are only
25 democracies in the world,
and in 2000,
there are more than 120.
In fact, when Colin
Powell's people asked me
to brief him on what the challenges were
for the democracy and human rights policy.
They said, we'd like you to start with
maybe a presentation of about 15 seconds.
(laughing)
I thought about it and I said to my staff,
get me two maps, one is a
map of the world in 1970
with all the democracies in blue
and all the nondemocracies in red.
Then get me another one
for 2000, same thing.
And then when he said, are
you ready for your briefing?
I said, you know Secretary
Powell, I want to,
I want you to look at these two
maps that what you notice is
there are a lot more democracies now
than there were 30 years ago,
but the countries that are in red,
the nondemocracies, are
the ones that are giving us
the most human rights problems.
The countries that are in blue
are the ones we can
cooperate with the most
to try to address those problems.
And the major difference
is that you now have
many, many more countries
with whom you can cooperate
to deal with a much smaller
number of countries.
So, your success in achieving this policy
will be your capacity to
mobilize the blue countries
to address the red countries.
Now, I still think that's right.
I think that's what we should
have done with regard to 9/11.
- It seems like they didn't listen.
Or some parts of the government.
- I think Secretary Powell listened.
And I think he had that view anyway,
I'm not sure that others in
the government listened to him,
- As an academic
and somebody whose home
base is the university,
and just listening to you talk yesterday,
giving the lecture, the Jefferson
lecture, and then today,
I have a sense of the strong
idealism that motivates you,
And by that I mean, an image of the future
and working toward that as you
deal with concrete problems.
How do you deal with the
situation in government
when things go terribly wrong
as obviously happened in Rwanda.
That was probably before
you were in the government,
but, but, but you could
reflect on that situation
where the good guys may
not always do as much good
as they can at a particular moment.
- Well, I think that we
learned a lot from Rwanda,
because there were danger signals
that were clearly ignored.
And I think what we learned
was, and then at the end,
they were intentionally
ignored, to be honest,
I think nobody was ready to
make the commitment necessary
to prevent something from
happening and I think in the end,
people didn't know how
bad it was going to be.
And I think the major
lesson I take away is,
when those signals are so unmistakable,
you should not ignore them.
I think it's the second point as well,
which is why do you serve
in the US government?
I was very lucky, I
was a tenured professor
and one thing I decided to myself is,
there's always gonna be
somebody in this job.
If you care more about your principles
than you do about your job
then you will never fail,
because you'll always be
viewed as having principles.
And so, I have to be prepared
to threaten to resign if necessary.
Now it wasn't a bad threat for me because
if I was fired, I could go back
to a tenured professorship.
But I was very struck,
six American foreign service
officers resigned during Bosnia
before there was a commitment
to the Dayton Accords.
And I asked a couple of
them, why did you resign?
And they told me they had
gone to the Holocaust Museum
when it opened and they
were looking around
and they saw cables that were sent
from the US State Department
about the Holocaust
and responses, which
were essentially saying,
we don't know if anything's
happening or not.
And they realized that
they were ignoring
similar signals in Bosnia
and that if they did that,
they would feel as
responsible as if they had
witnessed the Holocaust and
not done anything about it.
So, a couple of them came
back and resigned on the spot.
And those actions,
those acts of principle,
I think really pushed the
Clinton administration
to really step up too
and face the problem.
- Now we were on a trajectory before 9/11.
You discussed that with us just now,
and really a commitment to building
this international normative structure,
and as you said, this was pushed aside
by the choices,
through choices made by
the Bush administration.
I'm curious as to why
you think that happened.
I know you believe those
decisions were wrong,
but what is your analysis of the dynamic
that would create such a reversal,
a reversal that even went against what
many former officials of
the first President Bush
thought was a way to approach
some of these problems?
- Well, I'm trying to put
myself in their shoes.
I think the Bush administration
saw a radical discontinuity,
I call it Achilles and his heel.
You know, on the one hand,
we're the most powerful country.
On the other hand, we clearly
have an Achilles heel.
We could be attacked and
3,000 people can be killed.
So, how do we defend ourselves?
We adopt an approach of Homeland Security,
which they construed to
mean more security at home
and pre-emptive self-defense
toward people abroad.
And then I think their focus
on Human Rights shifted
from freedom to, freedom
to speak, to freedom from.
Freedom from fear was Franklin
Roosevelt's famous phrase.
I think they thought, we
need freedom from fear.
So, I think they essentially
inverted the framework
by which human rights analysis
had been going on for years,
because they thought there was
this radical discontinuity.
Now I think their great mistake
was to underestimate the strength
of the legal process that
surrounds what the US did.
You know, I describe it
as a legal exoskeleton.
The United States had
created a political order
and there was a legal framework
that kind of held it in place.
- Internationally.
And the United States designed this.
It was designed to help us.
We could mobilize it, for example,
we mobilized that legal
framework in the first Gulf War
to lawfully drive Saddam
Hussein out of Kuwait.
So, I think that what happened was,
the administration suddenly
felt this exoskeleton
as constraining and
they tried to break free
and it looked for awhile
as if they had done so,
but I think, you know, what
we're seeing as I speak,
which is in October 2003,
you know, that exoskeleton is
flexible, is closing back in.
The US government's
under a lot of pressure.
It's pretty clear that the
unilateral actions they take,
they've taken have really hurt
them, overseas and at home.
I think they're now
trying to figure out a way
to get Iraq reconstruction funded.
And so, I think what it shows
is that law is resilient
and that power has to
take law into account.
- Now, in 1990,
you wrote a book after your experience
in the Iran-Contra matter on the,
the National Security Constitution,
and one of your arguments
there was that the foreign policy
and I will state it briefly
and you can correct me if I'm wrong,
you know, could be made,
which reflected the,
the constitutional framework
which said that on issues
such as foreign policy,
there is, there is a shared responsibility
that although we have
separation of powers,
the dynamism between
the different branches
could make for a better policy
and that in the Iran-Contra
case that had failed.
And you went on to say
that you thought that there had been
a failure of power-sharing because
there had been a failure,
there had been executive initiative,
congressional acquiescence
to that initiative,
and a judicial tolerance
of letting the executive
do what it wanted,
or thought was best.
So, the question is,
does that analysis
apply in this situation?
I mean, why didn't the system
respond sooner to
the actions that the
Bush administration took,
which essentially put aside the framework.
Does your analysis apply to
what happened after 9/11?
- Very much so.
I think you stated the thesis well.
You know, the thesis of the book,
the National Security
Constitution was at the time,
many people were saying
the Iran-Contra affair
is kind of a blip, you know,
it's a failure of certain individuals.
Admiral Poindexter, Oliver North.
My argument was, this is systemic.
There are two competing visions
of how to run foreign policy.
One is executive dominance.
The other is what I call
a balanced institutional participation,
Congress, the president, and the courts.
And what I was really saying is
the principle of checks and balances
doesn't stop at the water's edge,
that, that all three
branches have to participate,
but that there had been this pattern
of executive overreaching,
congressional acquiescence,
and judicial tolerance, which was building
this counter-paradigm
of executive dominance.
Now the funny part was,
after I wrote the book,
we went through a period in which
the Clinton presidency had great weakness.
Newt Gingrich came, a lot of people said,
do now think you were wrong?
And I said, no.
I said, the pendulum will come back.
Look what happened right
in the wake of 9/11.
You know, the president
said, I want a Patriot Act.
You know, Congress extremely acquiescent,
the courts have up until this
point not really drawn a line.
So, we're now in a
situation in which finally
some cases are working their
way to the Supreme Court.
You know, particularly about,
can you hold the US citizen
indefinitely without a lawyer,
calling him an enemy combatant?
That's the Jose Padilla case.
And I think in the end, we're
basically looking to see
whether the president's
power can be restrained
by either Congress or the courts.
Just analogize it back to The
Steel Seizure Case of 1952.
- That was which case now?
- The Youngstown Sheet &
Tube, The Steel Seizure Case.
Harry Truman seized the steel mills
in Youngstown, Ohio,
during the Cold War
and the Supreme Court said,
you can indefinitely
seize American property
at home in time of war.
Now if that's so, how can you seize
an American citizen indefinitely
in time of even a war against terrorism?
So, what we're gonna see now is,
which image of foreign
affairs decision-making
will the Supreme Court accept?
Will it be this executive dominance model
or will it be this power-sharing model?
And I would argue it ought to
be the power-sharing model.
I think the most important point
is, the power-sharing model
is not just good for
Congress and the courts,
it's good for the president.
You know, when the
president goes it alone,
he may have greater
freedom in the early going
based on his popularity polls,
but when his popularity starts to drop,
he needs the support of Congress
and he needs the
legitimation of the courts
to carry on a balanced
constitutional foreign policy.
And I think that's what we're seeing
with President George W. Bush now.
He started with tremendous popularity
and then, you know,
over time it diminished
and now a majority of the American people
are criticizing the way he's
conducting our foreign policy.
If he had gotten a statute
that clearly supported him,
if he'd gotten a judicial ruling
that clearly said he was in the right,
he'd be on much stronger footing.
And I think it's in his
interest to seek those.
- And in the case of this
particular administration,
it seems they've gone out on a limb
and the the route they
taken doesn't work actually.
So, it's not just that
they violated the norms,
but the norms were in place for a reason
and now they're out on the limb,
which an election may
saw off, so to speak.
- Yeah, I mean, I think that again,
it's this idea of a legal exoskeleton
that is not just a restraint,
but it's also a source of power.
If you stay within the legal exoskeleton,
you're exercising legal power.
When you step outside, you're
sacrificing your legitimacy.
And the big challenge
for this administration,
can they fight outlaws while
staying within the law?
And I think that there's been
too much of a tendency to say,
fight fire with fire,
legal niceties don't count,
and then find that we are
viewed as big an outlier
as some of the countries
that we're criticizing,
and that weakens our cooperative
power, our soft power.
I guess I'd put it this way.
There are two kinds of, Joe
Nye the political scientist
says he distinguishes
America's hard power,
military and economic power
from its soft cooperative
persuasive power.
And I see the rule of
law and our reputation
for promoting the rule
of law, human rights,
as core to our soft power.
And we have been
squandering that reputation
and relying on our hard power.
Well, it turns out hard power
is good for defeating Iraq,
it turns out it's not
good for rebuilding Iraq,
that we need soft power
and we are sacrificing that soft power.
We're squandering it at a
time when we need it the most.
- And one has the sense
that the very problems
that the Bush administration
is, are now confronting
in Iraq are the ones that
we worked on in the '90s.
that we were building up a
way of thinking about them,
working through them and they sort of had
pushed all that off of the table and now
they're foisted by their own petard.
- Yes, one argument I made
in the Jefferson lecture is,
did the United States have an option
other than to attack Iraq
with the British government
in the Spring of 2003?
And I think the Bush
administration framed it as,
attack Iraq with the Brits
or do nothing.
And let's not continue with
weapons of mass destruction
and gross human rights violations.
Well, I think many people then said,
well, if this is the choice,
better to get him out.
What I have been arguing
is that, you know,
there was a third way that
was developed a long time ago.
How was Milosevic removed?
The United States put pressure on him,
collectively, cooperatively
created a tribunal
where he could be tried,
encouraged popular democracy to thrive.
He was gradually forced to leave.
A democratic government replaced him
and he went to the Hague.
So, if the United States
government had used a similar plan.
You know, disarm Iraq without attack,
get Saddam to leave
without military force,
we could have maintained our legitimacy
without resorting to this
radical coercive alternative.
So, I think those are that are
in the Clinton administration
I know have essentially felt
like there was a game plan,
there was a blueprint that
you could have followed
that was followed with
regard to Milosevic.
Here, they didn't follow it,
and they took a route that
looked better in the short-term,
and it's turned out to be
much worse in the long run.
- General Wesley Clark has an article
in the forthcoming issue
of the New York Review
where he essentially argues
that one of their failures
was to not draw on
what had become an interagency process
during the Clinton administration
to actually lay out within the government,
you know, planning about how one prepares
for the transition to democracy.
- In Kosovo and East
Timor and Sierra Leone,
all of these were, you know,
post-conflict societies
in which major peacekeeping
rebuilding efforts were made.
One of the great tragedies of Iraq,
Sergio Vieira de Mello
who was the UN administrator in Kosovo
and the UN administrator in East Timor
goes to Baghdad and he's
killed in a bomb attack.
Why, in part because the
necessary preconditions,
the security arrangements
and other things weren't established.
So, I think he knew even
at the time that he's going
that he was entering a much
more dangerous situation
in which basic groundwork
hadn't been laid.
It's a tremendous tragedy for everybody,
that we didn't learn
the lessons of the past.
- I want to ask you, do
you feel that there was
a political failure domestically
in the United States
among elected people in the
Congress to oppose the war?
Did they not meet the test
that you defined in your book?
- Yes.
- [Harry] Yes, they failed?
- They failed.
- Yeah.
- Well, let me give one example, you know,
the Patriot Act passed
with one dissenting vote,
Russ Feingold.
The Patriot Act circulated in draft
when most of Congress
was out of their offices,
because of anthrax.
So, many of them didn't even read it
and you know, you're passing
a law that you didn't read,
it's called the Patriot Act,
the authorization for use of force
essentially permitted the
president to attack any country
that he thought was a threat after 9/11.
It didn't name names, you know,
declarations of war,
name particular country.
So, as open-ended or is
one of the most open-ended
authorizations since the
Gulf of Tonkin Resolution.
Now, I think with regard to Iraq,
the Congress made an
absolutely critical error.
In the first Gulf War,
the president went to the Security Council
and he got a resolution
authorizing an attack, but setting limits
and then Congress
authorized him to use power
necessary to enforce
the limited Security Council resolution.
That was the right sequence.
In this Gulf War, 2003,
the president goes to Congress and says,
just give me a resolution,
which I can use without regard to whether
there's a Security
Council resolution or not.
So, they gave essentially
an open-ended Security Council resolution
before the election.
Once he has that resolution,
he doesn't need a Security Council,
once he has a Congressional resolution,
he doesn't need a Security
Council resolution.
So, then he goes to the
Security Council and says,
I'm going to attack Iraq
whether you say so or not.
And then they go back and forth
and in the end he abandons the effort
to get a Security Council resolution
that would authorize the attack.
And then he says, quite
in my mind unbelievably,
by the way, the old
Security Council resolution
justifies today's attack.
It's pretty strange to think that France
in 1991 was authorized in
the attack of Iraq in 2003
when Chirac is sitting
there in 2003 saying,
I'm going to veto any resolution.
So, I think that Congress
failed in terms of the way
in which they saw their responsibilities.
They should not have been
giving a blank check.
Now I think the president
was short-sighted also.
He saw this blank check as
somehow in his interest,
but he's paying a price,
because now it's Bush's war,
you know, he didn't have
congressional approval at the time.
So, I mean, it's too open-ended.
And so, now Congress can
walk away from the war.
So, I'm not blaming any particular entity.
I think everybody covered themselves with,
with unglory in this episode.
The president, I think, acted
without real consultation,
without getting specific authorization.
Congress, I think, bailed
out, ran for cover,
and I think Congress,
I'm sorry, the courts
haven't yet adjudicated,
particularly in these detention issues,
but their challenge is coming up.
- Now in a way, all of
this comes together,
all that we've been talking
about, the difference between
the Clinton and the Bush administration,
the new problem after 9/11 that is the,
the threat from either rogue
states or terrorist groups
obtaining nuclear weapons
and trying to use them
on the American homeland,
dictating in the Bush
administration's view
of pre-emptive strategy in the
case of North Korea actually.
So, I'd like to talk a little about that.
You can bring a special insight
at many levels,
your background, but also
your work as a lawyer
and in the government, and so on.
So, share with us some observations
how these two contrasting
views come together
in the question of how
to deal with North Korea.
- When I went to North
Korea in November 2000
with Madeleine Albright,
it was the highest visit by
an American official to meet Kim Jong-il.
From 1994 to 2001,
Kim Jong-il had entered
into this agreed framework
where he agreed to restrain
nuclear construction
in exchange for food, energy, et cetera.
You know basically, North Korea
is a failed state under his leadership
and the clear impression
that we had at the time was,
if we can lure Kim Jong-il
into participating in a legal framework,
he will start to do things
as part of this contractual agreement
that will bring him more and
more into the world system
it's not, to some it's the
idea of Nixon going to China.
And what I saw of him is, he's strange,
but he is not crazy
and he desperately wanted to
be closer to the world system.
He wants to be part of it.
He wants to be, in some
ways, recognized by it.
Our meeting went very well.
And then it was discovered that in fact,
he had been continuing
his nuclear development.
In other words, this agreed framework
had not worked perfectly.
- And this was, this discovery was made
in the Bush administration?
- Yeah, now my view is,
that's a little bit like discovering that
the speed limit is 60,
but people are going 65.
The fact that the law
is not working perfectly
doesn't mean that it's not
having a restraining force.
Nobody denied, in fact, the
Bush administration doesn't deny
that the existence of this legal framework
meant less nuclear weapons in North Korea
than there would have been,
plus it created a
framework of cooperation.
What they do is, they break off the talks.
And this now, and then start
making threatening statements
about Kim Jong-il, in particular,
this claim that he's
part of this axis of evil
that includes Iraq.
And then it becomes clear
that we're gonna attack Iraq.
Now, if you're Kim Jong-il,
you've been cooperating,
suddenly without much
change in your own behavior,
you're being identified as
part of this axis of evil.
I think he reasonably
concluded from his perspective,
I better get myself some
more bargaining chips.
And he started building more weapons
and then the United States was in a box,
because at this point we
didn't have the negotiators
who had negotiated the previous deal.
We'd abandoned the previous framework.
We had created this feeling of hostility
and we couldn't use military force,
because it was too dangerous to use it,
because of the proximity
of Seoul to North Korea.
So, what happened after a couple of years
in which this whole
framework disintegrates,
North Korea builds more weapons,
we start trying to develop
another multilateral framework.
We've moved from one agreed framework
to an effort to create a
second one and my view is,
we never should have
abandoned in the first place.
I'll tell you, Harry,
the greatest tragedy
from my perspective was
when we flew out of North
Korea into the South.
It was an incredible moment.
In North Korea, it's all
dark, there's no electricity
and we flew into South Korea,
then suddenly somebody
said, look there's Seoul.
And it was just, you
know, millions of lights.
And I thought to myself, that's democracy.
You know, these people
are the same people.
The only difference between
the North and the South
is a political system they lived under
and look at all this
light, all this prosperity.
And we landed and we
went to see Kim Dae-jung
who had worked with my father
and now a Nobel Peace Prize winner
and he says, I have this dream now,
North and the South can be
like a federated Germany
and they can try to deal
with an organization
for Security and Cooperation in Asia.
And we left and we flew back to America,
and I said to myself,
I'm gonna see Korea
reunited in my own lifetime.
And the thing he said that
really stunned me was,
at one point he said, Kim Dae-jung,
this is the president
of South Korea, he said,
I would like to see the
World Cup Semi-Final
played in North Korea.
What would happen,
the Bush administration
broke off the talks,
the World Cup Semi-Final
was played in South Korea.
I don't know if you remember,
but the people who played were
Germany and South Korea.
Now if Kim Dae-jung's
dream had been carried out,
a reunited Germany would
have played South Korea
in the World Cup in North Korea.
Every camera in the world
would have been there,
the North Koreans would have been cheering
for the South Koreans, it would
have opened up that country.
I mean, think about what
ping-pong diplomacy did to China,
much larger country.
They never could have,
they never could have
closed the box again.
A process would have begun
in Kim Jong-il's North Korea
that he could not have closed off.
Pandora's box of democracy
would have been opened
and I think about that all the time,
because I think that, you know,
since then it's been a couple steps back.
Now we're moving back
in the right direction.
But I really do,
I really do want to see Korea
reunited in my lifetime.
That was my father's dream and,
and you know, I'd like to
see that dream come true.
- As you talk it, it
strikes me that one of the,
the dilemmas that somebody like yourself
who is an academic
with a theoretical long-term perspective
moving to government is
the short-term perspective
that seems to be present often
when one is in government.
And I wonder if you would talk a little
about that frustration,
namely, you've just laid out
a beautiful long-term vision,
but in the short-term, you know,
things don't go the way
one would have wished for
if when we're moving toward the long-term.
Talk a little about that dilemma
of the academic in government.
- Well, I think that
the academic tends to have theories
and tends to have visions
and the practitioner
has to get things done.
And so, you know, the practitioner's focus
is almost always short-term
and the academic's focus
is always long-term.
I think the key though is,
I've tried to adopt a,
a mentality of what I
call pragmatic idealism.
You know, I believe that
civilization makes progress.
I mean, look at where we are now,
50 years after the Holocaust,
the things that are possible now
that weren't possible before,
and in the end, I think academic theories
have to not be based on
some theory of collapse or,
or failure but on some theory
of the possibilities of human cooperation.
The story that says it the best was,
when I was in Belgrade
in Christmas of 1999,
there was a radio station called B92,
which had been very critical of Milosevic
and Milosevic shut them down.
And in the last days
before they shut them down,
I guess actually it was December of '98,
they asked me to come in for an interview.
And I was talking to
an interviewer like you
in the studio just like this
and the guy was almost in tears.
And at the very end he said,
we are about to go off the air,
and he said, what can you say
to our listeners that will give them hope?
And I said, Madeleine Albright
was born in Nazi Germany.
She fled from the Communists
and now she's secretary of state
of the most powerful country in the world.
My father,
you know, was exiled from
a dictatorial government in South Korea
and now his son is the assistant
secretary for Human Rights
of the United States, and guess what,
both of our countries are free,
the Czech Republic is free.
South Korea is a burgeoning democracy
and I said and Yugoslavia will be too.
And you know, it's true.
You know, Belgrade is
in a post-Milosevic era.
So, I can be discouraged about 9/11,
but I can't look at my own life
and not feel as if as an
academic or as a practitioner,
pragmatic idealism should not be my focus
and fundamental optimism
about the possibilities of civilization.
- And really, the bottom
line here in these, these,
this positive direction
that you're talking about
is really what we started
with, your interest,
namely the effect of
transnational processes
on both individuals and states
and also the internal
processes of those states.
- I've come to think of the
idea of transnational process
as like medicine.
When I first put the idea out,
a lot of political scientists said to me,
what's your theory,
what's your prediction?
As if this was a sort
of scientific process
that's gonna play out.
And as I worked on it, I started to think,
you know, it's not so
much a scientific theory
as it is a blueprint for action.
And we need able practitioners
who are gonna push this process along.
Yeah, I don't think human history
just plays out inevitably.
I think it's contingent on human action.
So, when people say to me,
what does your theory now predict?
I would say, you know,
will the patient died
or will the patient live?
You know, it depends. (laughing)
You know, it depends on how
good a doctor he or she has
and how quickly they identify what's wrong
and how far they push
for the right results.
- So, it's a craft.
- It's a craft.
And my view is, there
was a choice after 9/11.
I think we made a lot
of the wrong choices.
I think we're now starting to recognize
that we made the wrong choice.
So, you know, even when we make mistakes,
there's a self-correcting
nature of the system,
but I think you know,
it's the job of people
who care about this system
of making progress to push
it in the right direction.
That's why I'm very inspired
by the quote from Robert
Kennedy at Cape Town in 1960s.
He says, you know,
every time a person stands
up against injustice,
they sent forth a tiny ripple of hope,
which crossing one another
from a million centers
of energy and daring,
create a tide that can bring down
the mightiest walls of injustice.
And when you think about it,
he's really talking about
what one person can do in
transnational legal process
to change the world.
Now when he said it, he was in Cape Town
and now South Africa is a
constitutional democracy.
And you know, I think there are
people who are living proof,
Martin Luther King, Nelson
Mandela, Mahatma Gandhi,
that you know, having
this pragmatic idealism,
connecting intellect to
action, a theory to practice,
has the possibility to change
the world for the better.
- Professor Koh, on that very
hopeful and positive note,
thank you very much for joining us
and sharing this fascinating
intellectual Odyssey with us.
- Thank you very much for
having me, I really enjoyed it.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(fast classical organ music)